what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so for reeling
for true this is the last issue before
we get into fall of Hawks
I don't know about you guys but I am
aching to get into fall of hooks I'm
dying for it I'm just like I almost want
to skip over all this and just jump into
fall of hooks because I love that story
it's one of my favorite horror stories
that and world war Hawks is awesome when
like there's one called a Hulk out
heroes there's a story work deadpool
becomes the incredible it's awesome like
hope pool is really really cool but what
this does is this picks up with again
much like the first volume of red hulk i
guess the first one with hulk with doc
Samson effectively analyzing a crime
scene now of course what he's doing is
he's actually showing us that someone
was fighting against Red Hulk not only
that the indication initially seems to
be here that someone killed Red Hulk and
it's really kind of cool to see all this
because Red Hulk is getting pummeled
left and right this is a huge deal
because what dr. Samson says is whoever
was that was fighting the Red Hawk
basically planned this down with
surgical precision
they basically knew exactly how to hit
the Red Hulk they knew were his weak
points were they knew how fast they
needed to be somebody that knew him
inside and out took it to Red Hulk and
basically seemed to kill him not only
that he's joined by Captain America as
well as Carol Danvers now something that
I want to point out here so I want to be
clear about this is not Captain America
Steve Rogers this is still Bucky Barnes
now we'll get to that a little bit more
here in a second but as they're going
through and they're analyzing the crime
scene subtly the entire story is turned
on his head and we learned this is
general Thunderbolt Ross that's wearing
was basically the Redeemer armor now
this is armor that was created by shield
for the sole purpose of defeating the
Incredible Hulk now is not the first
time something like this has popped up
in the realm of Marvel Comics there have
been all kinds of weapons that have been
used to either contain or kill the Hulk
for example the Hulkbuster armor of Tony
Stark is the most popular of course 20
Sark also has Phoenix Buster armor and
Thor Buster armor there's all kinds of
different armors out there that are
designed to serve the purpose of
defeating extremely powerful enemies but
what doc Samson also tells us is that
while general Thunderbolt Ross had the
Red Hulk at his mercy the mistake that
he made was basically revealing him
the mistake that he made was showing his
identity and effectively being arrogant
and the result of this was that Red Hulk
lashed out and killed general
Thunderbolt Ross now this was crazy when
it happened I was like oh my god
because I thought it was general
Thunderbolt Ross the whole time I was
like what red hulks got to be general
Thunderbolt Ross I mean who else is it
going to be you know it's gotta be him
you know it has to be him but then to
turn around and see general Thunderbolt
Ross killed by the Red Hulk I was like
well there goes that theory
now again touching back into Captain
America is something that I want to
point out here is that Steve Rogers is
still back he's returned from time
displacement which you know Marvel
basically brought him back from it's
kind of weird but his return is one of
the it's it's shameful almost kind of
wish he'd stayed dead to be honest but
then again we wouldn't have Hydra
Captain America and that would have been
disappointing because Nick Spencer your
writing is amazing but because of the
fact of the mantle of Captain America
was basically passed on to him after
Steve Rogers died Marvel was still
trying to figure out what they wanted to
do because this was really the only
thing that Bucky Barnes could be I mean
he was one thief or II D Brubaker to
bring him back and blow everyone's mind
when Sharon Carter you know there's that
constant image that iconic image when
she's like I think it's Bucky and it's
officially the return of Bucky Barnes it
was one thing to do that it was another
to say okay what next what do we do next
because Ed Brubaker had a planned out
that Steve Rogers was going to die
editorial control brought Steve Rogers
back so it's like well a Steve Rogers is
here Steve Rogers is Captain America and
we he's played other characters over the
years but when it comes down to it he's
Captain America you can't have him beat
anyone but Captain America and so
everyone knew that at some point or
another Bucky Barnes was gonna hand the
title back over to Rogers again so the
question was on what do you do then now
honestly they really didn't have
anything to do with Bucky Barnes until
we got original sin and he became the
man on the wall which honestly has been
a great role for him if you guys aren't
reading Thunderbolts right now you're
missing out on a really good story it's
actually pretty awesome it comes out of
Pleasant Hill and Avengers standoff I
think it is but it's a really cool run
of comics right now I like what you're
doing with uh with with Bucky Barnes
there we go my mind went blank for a
second but what this does is this kind
of jumps forward to the funeral of
Thunderbolt Ross now this is not in a
central part of fall of Hulk's it's not
the most necessary thing but I did this
and I'm bringing
for what happens at the end now what
takes place here is pretty
straightforward it's pretty
self-explanatory general Thunderbolt
Ross has a huge history and Marvel
Comics he's been around for quite some
time now keep in mind while this is
going on Hickman's Fantastic Four is
taking place and that's one of the
reasons why the Fantastic Four aren't
really here in the traditional sense I
mean you have them that are kind of
stopping in for second to say yeah yeah
you know we know general Thunderbolt
Ross but it's one of the things that
fills in the holes of what were they
doing while Fantastic Four was going on
under Hickman's run what were some of
the things that were taking place so
that's why they're kind of here then
they're gone all of a sudden it's
because they're literally out having to
deal with the mad Celestials but the
cool thing here is that it's essentially
us being able to see this instance of
how influential Thunderbolt Ross was in
the lives of Marvel superheroes why say
Jeff Lowe is pretty good when it comes
to doing things like this of course we
still have Steve Rogers here but we also
have Rick Jones we have dr. Sampson that
kind of opens up the ceremonies by
talking about his experience with
general Thunderbolt Ross and is really
everybody just sort of humming in now of
course we do sidetrack for a second and
we are taken back to the Intelligencia
and we basically have red she-hulk
watching all these events unfold but we
also find out that red she-hulk's been
joined by Lyra by the future daughter of
The Incredible Hulk who's basically been
yanked back to this time period now the
reason why she's included here is
because witness being fall of hoax and
world war Hawks Jeff Lowe basically had
to grab all these different versions of
the Hulk's really Jeff Logan Greg pack
had to grab them all from every
conceivable possibility with the
exception of those who are like
alternate universes so like maestro
doesn't really count but he was grabbing
all these different versions of the Hulk
and bringing them into one location and
so it makes sense that we would see this
especially once we get into Skaar the
Sun of Hope but it's really just a
little bit of infighting here between
LED she-hulk and Lyra who's really like
savage she-hulk but there's a little bit
of then finding nothing too major but
these two characters will play important
roles later on so it was cool the Jeff
flow was kind of set in the seeds there
but again you know we really get like
colonel savage you know we get a few
people here and there who are coming in
and offering their own discussions the
real kicker though comes into play when
we get I would say thing you know Ben
Grimm will get you know Bruce Banner
here in a second but Ben Grimm offers
some cool exposition here because what
he basically says is general Thunderbolt
Ross is the reason why we fought the
Incredible Hulk for the first time and
that's really how it is like I said you
know in the last video we talked about
the Fantastic Four venus proving ground
for introducing new characters The
Incredible Hulk was introduced outside
of the Fantastic Four he was introduced
in his own
Ron but again the Fantastic Four is how
you boosted the popularity of stuff and
because of the fact of the Incredible
Hulk had always kind of been struggling
in the realm of Marvel Comics it made
sense that right off the bat he'd go
against the x-men he'd go against the
Fantastic Four we go against some of the
most prominent members of Marvel's
landscape in order to make sure that he
was popular in the eyes of fans and
that's what Ben Grimm says you know Ben
Grimm basically says hey look general
Thunderbolt Ross had an obsession with
the Incredible Hulk
it literally dominated his life he's the
reason why we first encountered the
Incredible Hulk
but what Ben Grimm also says is because
of the fact that general Ross was so
obsessed it ultimately led to us not
really viewing the Hulk as a friend per
se but understanding the struggle
between Bruce Banner and The Incredible
Hulk that it wasn't just some
black-and-white thing it wasn't like the
hoax a bad guy and we have to defeat him
it was a lot more complicated because
the Hulk was so human Bruce Banner is
such a normal human being but they had
to reconcile the differences between the
two now following Ben Rams bit of an
explanation we then get Bruce Banner and
this was actually really really cool
because when Bruce Banner steps up and
says hey look I knew general Thunderbolt
Ross better than any of you that's 100%
true I mean he says things you know like
glenn talbot you know basically what am
i a is believed that he died when he was
in russia you know he talks about Betty
Ross he basically says that for him as
an individual for him as Bruce Banner
slashed the Hulk he knows general
Thunderbolt Ross better than anybody
else because general Thunderbolt Ross
was basically his main bad guy now it's
funny that they're actually letting him
get up here and talk because this isn't
something you would normally see
whatever you go to funerals you never
really talked about like the mistakes
that people made like I don't know
anybody that goes to a funeral and says
yeah man you know the deceased that dude
was a dick like I don't really know
anybody who does that and if they did
it'd be done an extremely bad taste but
banner getting up here and speaking
speaks volumes to his respect for
general Thunderbolt Ross and the fact
that despite the fact they were mortal
enemies met in the end Ross was a guy
who did what he felt needed to be done
that if he thought the Incredible Hulk
need to be reeled in that the Incredible
Hulk need to be destroyed then he acted
on that with the utmost conviction and
would use all of his resources to pull
it off and so following Bruce banners a
bit of a statement here we basically go
out and of course he gets the 21 gun
salute that kind of thing the flag is
folded and so on and so forth but then
we actually pick up with the Arlington
National Cemetery later on that night
and we get Betty Ross now remember in
the last
video that we had talked about this is
what I say the ending is so important
here and the last video that we have
talked about Rio basically run over the
history of the intelligencia Betty Ross
was in stasis and so somewhere along the
line she'd been taken out of stasis been
revived and she's now back out here not
only that she's working alongside Glenn
Talbot and so now it means that Glenn
Thomas here and so what Jeff lobe is
doing is he's really building this
mystery saying one if everybody thought
that Glenn Talbot is dead then why is he
alive - if Betty Ross had effectively
been killed by abomination when he had
sped up the poisoning that she was
exposed to due to the fact that she
spent so much time with the Incredible
Hulk then how did she come back to life
how does all this work you know what's
going on here and so it creates a really
really cool situation not only that when
we jump back to the intelligence here
there's a lot of arguing and a lot of
infighting going on between MODOK
between the leader between dr. Samson
because what they're basically saying is
the Red Hulk was supposed to be on their
side but if red hope killed general
Thunderbolt Ross and it means the red
Hook's not on their side now keep in
mind in the video that we had talked
about we had done you know the whole
thing of Red Hulk going against will
reign in x-23 and all that kind of stuff
we had talked about how when red shield
was introduced that she was sent by the
intelligence here because of the fact
the Red Hulk had gone off the
reservation he was supposed to be there
to help them carry out their own aims
and instead the Red Hulk became obsessed
with destroying Bruce Banner and so
because Red Hulk had essentially gone
rogue the intelligence yet didn't quite
trust him what they're saying now is
their plan to reel him back in or else
destroy him is ultimately failed and
he's basically turned against them with
the intention of bringing them down and
so what MODOK says is what he's looking
for is infighting what the Red Hulk is
trying to do is to spur infighting
because it's a smart strategic move
that's what Napoleon would do Napoleon
would go in he would basically start
civil wars in countries weakened their
social economic system and then conquer
it that's how he would expand his empire
and it's a great maneuver to have
weakened people from the inside out to
the point that they can't sustain any
real measure of a battle and then
conquer them but the idea is that
because of the fact that MODOK is so
intelligent because MODOK is such a
formidable leader in his own right he
basically says we need to calm down what
we need to do is regather ourselves if
he's coming after us because he believes
if he can break us apart then what we
need to do is we basically need to step
in and we need to try to find a way to
eliminate him so this doesn't become a
problem and so what happens is we
basically pick up in a
and what we learn is that Red Hulk is
still alive Red Hawks talking to some
unknown person effectively a person that
he's forged an alliance with and we
learned that he's basically working with
Bruce Banner and so that's why I say
this is crazy
things are getting Wow because now we
have an alliance between Bruce Banner
and Red Hulk and so it's super cool it's
wild it's gonna lead in to follow folks
and some crazy things are gonna happen
that's why I said I really wanted to
throw this in before fall of hook
started because I felt like it really
adds to the mystery and the intrigue but
if you guys are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace